et maintenant le best-of de stéphane
guillon
savoir stéphane êtes content de
travailler chez nous et bien je ne suis
pas sûr
thierry ardisson ou de continuer à faire
ma revue de presse chez vous je n'en
suis pas sûr je vous écrire une lettre à
tous les impétrants
travaillons à canal+ yann barthès michel
denisot et les guignols afin qu'il
reprenne mes propositions sur l'humour
en france la galéjade hexagonal et la
satire gauloise et j'irai tiers des
sceaux gerin nous irons chez rare
chez ceux et celles qui me seront les
pompes les brodequins les cinq ans que
les boutiques
j'ai pris la grosse tête ce n'est un
secret pour personne
j'ai une hypertrophie du moi
et j'ai envie comme cela que le
courtisent commente lagord
fin de citation c'est bien les
sensibiliser à paris au studio de trois
mètres carrés vendus 29 1000e rôle
annonces sur internet a choqué pourtant
la nouvelle propriétaire est ravi c'est
immense at elle déclaré depuis longtemps
je rêvais d'un loft
michel larqué fait l'objet d'une plainte
pour antisémitisme va commenter le match
france roumanie aux côtés de thierry
roland spécialiste lui aussi des
dérapages verbaux une retransmission qui
devrait tenir toutes ses promesses oh
lala lala bogdan stancu s'écroule dans
la surface alors qu'il n'a pas été
touché par le français une attitude 100%
romaine thierry n'oublions pas que ce
sont des voleurs de poules ils ont le
vice dans le sang effectivement jean
michel souvenez vous quand ils
braquaient nos packs mètres à l'aide de
tournevis absolument ils sont aussi très
agressif à chaque fois qu'on s'arrête à
un feu rouge il loue [ __ ] le pare
brise avec leur éponge noir l'ancrage
vous avez raison jean min et passez moi
l'expression ça ne sent pas toujours la
rose
absolument absolument thierry alors que
stancu est toujours à terre l'arbitré
siffle la fin du match j'espère que les
français ont bien verrouiller leurs
vestiaires avant l'heure de gagner un
terrain je serai je me méfierais et si
boulogne vous pas
dsk a voté pour martine aubry symbole de
la gauche dure l'ancien directeur du fmi
a justifié son choix
je suis prêt gauche dure
toujours qu'est ce que c'est je
jure pierre dissaux
c'est être réactif
à l'étranger spl
colloque international quel besoin les
personnes qu'on croise hôtesses de ce
cratère d'un bibi
vous d'être ferme
ferme sur ses positions au vert mais
qu'est ce que c'est et thierry ardisson
que j'ai ouvert
moderne c'est le pa moli jamais
quoi qu'il arrive après quelques
secondes de plaisir de jouissance
yoanna quitte à sacrifier un destin une
ambition tout plutôt que vous êtes en
dur
tir du jour
tu philosophie
rémy pflimlin le pdg de france
télévisions s'est félicité du succès de
la nouvelle émission de france dédié
giesbert alors que celles ci n'avaient
pas été diffusées à l'antenne la semaine
prochaine rémy pfimlin devrait se
féliciter du retour de pascal sevran sur
france 2
excuse moi pascal
je voulais pas être désagréable michel
drucker a été à ton enterrement oui il y
bat toujours merci
dominic besner l'ancien agent de
ségolène royal a été ému par les larmes
de la candidate aux primaires a même
mois deux mois a été bouleversé tout
d'un coup c'est celle à ségo qu'on aime
assez plus la foldingue habité d'une
mission divine qui scandent fraternité
fraternité que les cloches y est tout
d'un coup bas télé mode chaussée greta
garbo c'est la diviser bacall dont
casablanca de 9 dans le dernier métro
tel titanic les magnifiques silva toile
va rebondir à c'est une femme forte à le
poitou charentes une terrienne et avec
ses tenues blanches et rouges elle va
retrouver du travail chez darty à gbagbo
a sauvé ses gotha peut devenir la
coqueluche de l'électroménager si elle
avait été élue elle voulait proposer un
contrat à la nation c'est darty c'est le
cofrade confiant ça c'est la même chose
à nous elle va faire un malheur aller à
la semaine prochaine voilà c'était le
geste of the union que vous retrouverez
ici la semaine prochaine
et d'ici là sur canalplus.fr les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux